GREAT STORY.
>> DONE.
>> SEAN: WELCOME TO HANNITY.
TONIGHT, HALT OF A POSSIBLE
TREATMENT NOW EXISTS.
IT SEEMS VERY VERY REAL.
WE WILL HAVE A BIG REPORT AND AS
ALWAYS WE WILL BRING YOU FACTS
WITHOUT FEAR, WITHOUT HYSTERIA,
WITHOUT PANIC.
WE ARE THE LAND OF THE FREE AND
THE HOME OF THE BRAVE, THOSE ARE
NOT JUST WORDS.
ALSO TONIGHT VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE WILL BE JOINING US.
WE WILL ALSO HEAR FROM A
COVID-19 PATIENT.
HIS LIFE WITH SAVED, HE WAS ON
DEATHS DOOR.
HIS DOCTOR SAID THERE’S NOTHING
ELSE HE COULD DO.
HE SAID GOODBYE TO HIS FAMILY.
THEN HE WAS TREATED WITH AN
ANTI- MALARIA DRUG AND IT WAS A
TRULY MIRACULOUS RECOVERY.
ARE WE CLOSE TO A TREATMENT THAT
MAY POTENTIALLY SAVE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF LIVES?
WE WILL INVESTIGATE TONIGHT AND
A REPORT ON HOW JUST REPULSE OF
THE MOB AND THE MEDIA, HOW THEY
REALLY ARE.
TONIGHT WE START WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEY ARE
DESPICABLE BEHAVIOR OVER THE
WEEKEND, LAWMAKERS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE HAMMERED OUT
TRILLION DOLLAR EMERGENCY
SPENDING BILL.
THAT PROPOSED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO FOUR WORKERS, SMALL
BUSINESSES, FOR STRUGGLING BIG
INDUSTRIES LIKE THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY, BILLIONS FOR HOSPITALS
AND CASH PAYMENTS TO AMERICANS
THAT NEED IT, THAT ARE MAKING
UNDER $99,000 A YEAR.
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS ARE HURTING
.
WE REBUILT EUROPE, WE SAVE THE
WORLD FROM EVIL INTO YOUR ANY
TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
NOW IT’S TIME TO HELP OUT OUR
AMERICAN FAMILY.
WHAT HAPPENS UNEXPECTEDLY, THIS
MORNING, THEY’VE TORPEDOED THE
BILL, THEY ARE NOW SAYING THEY
WILL NOT PASS ANYTHING THAT DOES
NOT INCLUDE IN INSANE LAUNDRY
LIST OF UNRELATED ITEMS.
NOTHING TO DO WITH CORONA.
I PREDICTED THIS WOULD HAPPEN.
WHY ARE THEY DELAYING CRITICAL
AID AND FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
AMERICAN WORKERS COME OUT SMALL
BUSINESSES, LARGE BUSINESSES,
THAT IF HAD TO SHUT DOWN?
THIS IS WHAT THEY WANT.
THEY WANT TAX CREDITS FOR
WINDMILLS AND SOLAR POWER.
THEY WANT THEIR GREEN NEW DEAL
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER SO THEY’RE
WILLING TO DENY DESPERATE
AMERICANS IN NEED FOR THIS.
THEY ALSO WANT NEW ADMISSION
MANDATES FOR THE AIRLINE
INDUSTRY.
MANDATORY REPORTING OF
GREENHOUSE GRAT GAS STATISTICS
FOR EARLY EVERY AIRLINE FLIGHT.
IN OTHER WORDS, LET’S JUST KICK
YOU ALL IN THE TEETH THAT WORK
IN THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY WHEN
YOU’RE DOWN.
AMERICANS NEED TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE, PAY THEIR RENT, THEIR
MORTGAGES, THE CAR PAYMENTS TELL
THEIR KIDS THAT THEY’RE NOT
GOING HAVE TO PULL THEM OUT OF
COLLEGE.
WHERE ARE THEIR PRIORITIES
TONIGHT AS THE NATION WAITS LIKE
WITH THE VIRUS, WHAT ARE THE
DEMOCRATS DOING.
WHAT WERE THEY DOING WHEN THE
PRESIDENT IMPLEMENTED THAT
CRUCIAL CRITICAL TRAVEL BAN.
THAT’S RIGHT, THEY WERE
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT, AND
FORGET COLD JOE.
HE CALLED THE PRESIDENT ZINA
PHOBIC, AND OF YOUR MONGREL.
HOW AS PART OF A NEW FANTASY,
THEY ARE TRYING TO PUT AIRLINE
COMPANIES OUT OF BUSINESS, THEY
ARE GOING TO LET AMERICANS LIVE
IN A STATE OF ANXIETY AND WORRY
AND FEAR BECAUSE THEY’RE NOT
DOING THEIR JOBS.
THIS IS WHAT GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
SERVE THE PEOPLE.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO DEMANDING
BROAD NEW POWERS FOR LABOR
UNIONS.
THE FORGIVENESS OF STUDENT LOAN
DEBT, NEW RULES SURROUNDING
RACIAL DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS, SUBSIDIES FOR NEWSPAPERS
AND SO MUCH MORE.
WHAT DOES THIS HAVE TO DO WITH
PEOPLE THAT NEED HELP NOW?
THE DEMOCRATICALLY MAJORITY WHIP
CALLED IT A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO RESTRUCTURE
THINGS, TO FIT OUR VISION.
SMALL BUSINESSES SUFFERING
ENTIRE INDUSTRIES, LIKE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY, OUR
STRUGGLING.
THEIR WORKERS ARE LOSING THEIR
JOBS.
THEY ARE AFRAID THEY MAY LOSE
THERE HOMES OR GET KICKED OUT OF
THEIR APARTMENTS.
WHAT IS THEIR AGENDA?
HE’S WORRIED ABOUT RESTRUCTURING
THINGS TO FIT THEIR RATTLE IT
RADICAL SOCIALIST VISION.
THAT IS THE RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST PARTY AND THAT IS THEM
BEING A NATIONAL DISGRACE AGAIN
BECAUSE THEY’VE DONE NOTHING FOR
THREE YEARS ANYWAY.
THEY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF THIS
CONDUCT, BUT EMMA KRATZ, FOR
THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE SOME
SENSE, REASON, COMPASSION,
UNDERSTANDING, ARE YOU
EMBARRASSED ABOUT WHAT THIS
PARTY HAS BECOME?
WHAT HAS YOUR PARTY DONE IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS TO HELP SAFETY
AND SECURITY, PEACE AND
PROSPERITY?
HAY, TRIM, THAT’S ALL THEY’VE
DONE.
EVEN TIME DURING GREAT URGENCY,
WHEN OUR FELLOW AMERICANS NEED
THEIR GOVERNMENT TO ACT, THEY
CARE MORE ABOUT THE RADICAL
AGENDA THAN HELPING AMERICAN
WORKERS, SMALL BUSINESS, BIG
BUSINESS.
AS MITCH McCONNELL SAID,
DEMOCRATS WON’T LET US FUN
HOSPITALS OR IS SAVE SMALL
HOSPITALS UNLESS THEY GET TO
DUST OFF THE GREEN NEW DEAL AND
PUT A CARBON FOOTPRINT LANGUAGE
INTO THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DEMOCRATS WON’T LET US FUN
HOSPITALS WERE SAVE SMALL
BUSINESSES UNLESS THEY GET TO
DUST OFF THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THIS IS THE MOMENT TO DEBATE NEW
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE NOTHING
WHATSOEVER TO DO WITH THIS
CRISIS?
THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE UP TO OVER
THERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
WHAT.
HOW CAN HAVE THE SENATE NOT RISE
TO THE OCCASION?
AT A TIME WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE IN
THE COUNTRY IS PULLING TOGETHER.
THEY ARE PULLING US APART.
>> GOOD FOR MITCH McCONNELL, I
CAN’T RECALL HIM BEING THAT
ANGRY, AND RIGHTFULLY SO.
WHEN AMERICANS NEED HELP THE
MOST, THEIR IS A RADICAL
SOCIALIST, THEY ARE CARING ABOUT
CARBON FOOTPRINTS IN THEIR OWN
POLITICAL AGENDA.
NOW THEY’RE TAKING A PAGE OUT OF
THE PLAYBOOK OF RAHM EMANUEL.
HOW ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN CHICAGO
GETTING SHOT YOU’RE AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
HE SAID YOU NEVER LET A SERIOUS
CRISIS GO TO WASTE, AND
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THINGS YOU
COULD NOT DO BEFORE.
GAS WHAT, HE IS ON STATE RUN
CONSPIRACY TELEVISION MSNBC WHEN
HE GAVE DEMOCRATS THE EXACT SAME
ADVICE.
GIG IS SOMEBODY ONCE ALSO SAID
WHEN I WORKED FOR PRESIDENT
OBAMA, NEVER ALLOW A CRISIS TO
GO TO WASTE.
THIS WILL NOT BE OUR LAST
EPIDEMIC.
BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO ENSURE, AND
THIS IS WHAT PRESIDENTIAL
LEADERSHIP COMES, THAT THIS WILL
NOT BE THE LAST PANDEMIC, BUT IT
MUST BE THE LAST ECONOMIC
DEPRESSION BECAUSE OF A PANDEMIC
.
AND THEN START SETTING OUT HOW
TO USE THIS CRISIS TO INVEST IN
PUBLIC HEALTH.
>> TONIGHT EVERY AMERICAN HAS A
RIGHT TO BE ANGRY AND TICKED OFF
.
DEMOCRATS CANNOT PUT ASIDE THERE
PETTY POLITICS TO ACTUALLY HELP
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS IN NEED.
THIS IS BEYOND A BETRAYAL.
TO EVERY AMERICAN WORKER, THEIR
ARE PEOPLE THAT REALLY MAKE THE
COUNTRY GREAT, THOSE THAT ARE
STRUGGLING NOW, AND EVEN SOME
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF CONGRESS,
MAY BE A FEW SENSIBLE ONES
REPORTEDLY GROWING WEARY OF
THESE POLITICAL GAMES.
BUT NOT DOCTOR JOE.
JOE BIDEN TRYING TO USE THE
CORONAVIRUS TO SCORE CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS.
HE SAID FUNDRAISING OFF THE
VIRUS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED THE
TRAVEL BAN ON JANUARY 302,001
st 10 DAYS
AFTER THE FIRST CONFIRMED CASE
IN THE UNITED STATES, WHAT DID
BIDEN SAY?
THE PRESIDENTS TRAVEL BAN
QUARANTINE WAS ZINA PHOBIC, AND
NOW BIDEN IS GIVING THE SINGLE
MOST WAS OUR SERIES OF WEIRD,
ONLINE SPEECHES ABOUT HOW HE
WOULD BE HANDLING THE PANDEMIC
SO MUCH BETTER THAN DONALD TRUMP
.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS EVERYTHING
HE MENTIONED TRUMP DID A LONG
TIME AGO AND THE THINGS YOU
MENTIONED WOULDN’T OF DONE A
DIFFERENCE.
THE FIRST SPEECH HE FORGOT.
THAT SPEECH WHERE HIS WORK I
FORGOT I’M DOING THIS.
AND THEY HAD TO COVER THE
SCREENPLAY TODAY HE LOST HIS
TRAIN OF THOUGHTS.
WHAT A SHOCKER.
DOES HE EVEN KNOW WHAT DAY IT IS
?
BY THE WAY, IT’S NOT SUPER
THURSDAY.
STRUGGLING WITH A TELEPROMPTER.
>> IN ADDITION TO THAT, IN
ADDITION TO THAT, WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE IN A
POSITION THAT WE ARE--LET ME GO
TO THE SECOND THING.
WE NEED TO BUILD AN ARSENAL OF
DEMOCRACY AS WE DID IN 1940.
WE MAKE A PERSONAL PRODUCTIVE
EQUIPMENT.
HERE IS THE DEAL, WE HAVE TO DO
WHAT WE DID IN THE 40s AND THE
20 IN 2020.
>> OH, SORRY COME UP MORE ON HIS
CONFUSION AND BITTERLY PARTISAN
RESULT TO THE PANDEMIC.
HE’S BEEN DISGRACEFUL.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ON THIS PROGRAM.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED,
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PROSPECTS
ON THE HORIZON.
NEWS TO SHARE.
WHILE THE DEMOCRATS PLAY
POLITICAL GAMES TO SCORE CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS AND AN EXTREME
AGENDA.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
PRIVATE ARE STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE.
YOU ARE NOW WATCHING HISTORY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW REWRITING
EVERY RULE ON HOW NOT ONLY THIS
COUNTRY, BUT THE WORLD WILL DEAL
WITH FUTURE PANDEMICS.
THINGS WE’VE NEVER DONE BEFORE.
TRAVEL BANDS, I WONDER IF THAT
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED FASTER NEXT
TIME KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW NOW.
DRIVE-UP TESTING, PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS.
TELEMEDICINE IS COMING ONLINE.
HOW MANY EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS
COULD BE STOPPED IF PEOPLE AT
2:00 A.M. CAN CALL A DOCTOR ON
THEIR FACE TIME AND SAY MY SON
OR DAUGHTER HAS THE CROUP, AND
MAKING REALLY WEIRD NOISES LIKE
A SEAL, AND THEN WHAT DO I DO?
FIRST PUT SOME STEAM IN THE
SHOWER, IF THAT DOESN’T WORK,
CALL ME BACK IN AN HOUR.
MAY BE A THIRD, MAYBE MORE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS WOULD END.
COMPASSIONATE CARE, THE RIGHT TO
TRY TESTING NEW TREATMENTS OF
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS,
EVEN EVERY ONE OF THESE THINGS
IS INNOVATIVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON EVERY AREA
SETTING A NEW PRESIDENT AND
REWRITING THE BOOKS AS WE WATCH,
AS WE SPEAK.
HOW MANY AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
CONTRACTED THIS VIRUS BUT FOR
THE TRAVEL BAN AND THE
QUARANTINE.
THAT ONE DECISION TEN DAYS AFTER
THE FIRST KNOWN CASE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT WAS JANUARY 302,001st.
HOW MANY MORE MAY HAVE DIED
MOVING FORWARD WITH THESE NEW
RULES, THE NEW BOOK HE IS
WRITING, IN FRONT OF US, HOW
MANY LIVES WILL POTENTIALLY BE
SAVED IN THE FUTURE?
AMERICAS PRIVATE BUSINESSES ARE
ALSO TO THEIR GREAT CREDIT, YOU
KNOW, YOU LISTEN TO THE LIBERALS
, THEY OFTEN TRASH
WALMART, I ALWAYS SAY I LOVE
WALMART, I LOVE TARGET, I LOVE
THEM ALL.
LOOK AT THESE.
ALL OF THESE COMPANIES, AND EVEN
THE COMPANIES I’M NOT THAT FOND
OF.
ALL OF THEM DESERVE CREDIT
TONIGHT, DONATING SPACE, MONEY,
ENERGY, AND ASSISTANCE IN ANY
WAY THEY CAN HOPING TO GET THE
PRODUCTS TO THOSE IN NEED.
LOOK AT GM, LOOK AT FORD.
THEY’RE SAYING WE CAN MAKE
VENTILATORS, DO YOU NEED THEM?
SOME OF AMERICA’S TOP HOSPITALS
ARE MANUFACTURING THEIR OWN
PROTECTIVE GEAR, THAT’S WHY I
SAID AT ONE POINT, WE WILL
ULTIMATELY PROBABLY SAVE THE
WORLD AGAIN.
HOW MANY TIMES HAS AMERICA COME
TO THE RESCUE?
MEDICAL RESEARCH, DOCTORS,
SCIENCES, AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
WE KEEP THE WORLD FREE, WE BAIL
OUT AND REBUILD EUROPE.
TESLA, GM, FORD, AMERICA’S TOP
PHARMACEUTICAL COMPANIES, THOSE
EVIL DRUG COMPANIES DONATING
MEDICINE AND WORKING
AROUND-THE-CLOCK TO HELP DEVELOP
A VACCINE.
NEVER BEFORE HAVE WE BEEN ABLE
TO BREAK DOWN THE SEQUENCE OF A
VIRUS USED TO TAKE YEARS, WE DID
IN FIVE OR SIX WEEKS.
WE KNOW HOW FIRST TRIAL
POTENTIAL HOPEFULLY VACCINES IN
THE PROCESS.
SEVERAL BIG BUSINESSES ARE
HIRING.
MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF PEOPLE.
THOUSANDS OF NEW JOB POSTINGS AT
AMAZON AND 7-ELEVEN, AND WALMART
.
WALMART SAID THEY’RE HIRING
150,000 PEOPLE.
MAYBE NEED A BRIDGE JOB UNTIL
YOU GET YOUR JOB BACK.
I PUT THE LIST FULLY UP ON
HANNITY.COM.
OTHER ARE OFFERING BONUSES TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
MANY BIG-BOX STORES ARE OFFERING
TO PAY RAISES AND DOUBLE
OVERTIME.
THIS IS WHAT WE AS AMERICANS DO.
THIS IS WHO WE ARE.
WE COME TOGETHER, WE HELP ONE
ANOTHER IN A TIME OF NEED.
NOBODY SAW THIS COMING.
WE ALL WORK HARD, WE ALL FIND
SOLUTIONS, WE ARE INNOVATIVE, WE
ARE CREATIVE.
WHERE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA, THE GREATEST COUNTRY
GOD GAVE MAN.
YES, ONE NATION, WAS SEPARATED
BY A THING.
THE THING, GOD THAT CREATES
EVERYTHING.
U.S. DOCTORS AND SCIENTIST, THIS
IS THE BIG NEWS TONIGHT, ARE
SEEN SUCCESS WITH NEW TREATMENTS
, EXPERIMENTAL
TREATMENTS.
ON MY RADIO PROGRAM CALLED ONE
OF THOSE DOCTORS DETAILED HIS
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRESS IN HERE
IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU HAVE HAD 100 PERCENT
SUCCESS RATE.
>> I DEFINED SUCCESS AS NOT
HAVING TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL
SINCE HOSPITALS ARE OVERWHELMED
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE TREATED AGGRESSIVELY
THESE PATIENTS AND I’VE SEEN
REMARKABLE RESULTS WITHIN THE
SHORTNESS OF BREATH ISSUE
RESOLVED WITH AND FOR DESH SIX
HOURS.
>> THIS DOCTOR PUBLISHED THAT HE
AND HIS TEAM HAVE NOW TREATED
PATIENTS WITH THAT REGIMENT,
NONE OF THEM DIED, NONE OF THEM
WERE HOSPITALIZED, HE NOW HAS
350 CASED TEST CASES THAT HE’S
REFERRING TO.
SIMILAR METHODS ARE NOW BEING
TESTED ALL OVER THE WORLD FOR
EXAMPLE RESEARCHERS IN FRANCE
HAVE RELEASED A PRELIMINARY
STUDY SHOWING HOW A COMBINATION
OF HYDROXY AND ANTIBIOTICS CAN
BE USED TO MITIGATE SYMPTOMS OF
THOSE IMPACTED WITH THE VIRUS
AND HEALED THEM QUICKER.
ONE MORE GOOD PIECE OF
INFORMATION, WE LEARN TODAY AT
THE PRESIDENT’S PRESS CONFERENCE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE THANKFULLY ARE
NOT DYING OF CORONAVIRUS.
OF FIVE BIOPHYSICIST FROM
STANFORD MAD MODELED THE
OUTBREAK AND IS PREDICTING
FAIRLY QUICK AND TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND HE PREDICTED
ACCURATELY EVERYTHING THAT WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN CHINA.
AS OF MARCH 18th THERE HAVE
BEEN ZERO FATALITIES FROM
CHILDREN ONLY ONE DEATH OF ONE
TEENAGER WORLDWIDE.
YOU GET NERVOUS BASED ON THE NEW
NUMBERS FIRST WE WERE TOLD UP
UNTIL ABOUT A WEEK AGO IT WASN’T
IMPACTING KIDS THEN WE HEAR IT
IS, THAT MAKES IT MORE SCARY.
GOOD NEWS TONIGHT.
THIS IS A SERIOUS DISEASE, BACK
ON GENERATE 27th YOU GOT TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY WE’RE GOING TO
GET STRATEGIC, WE’RE GOING TO
FIND SOLUTIONS, YOU CAN’T PANIC.